hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen endlich mal wieder zurück zu
wittert das biest zusammen mit simon hey
hallo schön und was ihr zuerst schon
seht wir haben so ein tolles game menü
am rand und es ist alles ein bisschen
anders also das liegt einerseits an die
protection packs gerade mal nicht drin
hab ich das an die ford auch ganz schön
finde
und wir haben nicht mehr da wurf 20
sondern meint craig jetzt drin
das hat zum beispiel die vorteile achte
mal über meinen namen wenn ich schreibe
das schreiben schreibt du mal was guckt
da da das steht da alles über den namen
das ist eigentlich alles sehr sehr geil
und auch oben auf der minimap sehen wir
jetzt wo wir uns befinden und so was
alles also wir sehen echt so geile
sachen die seele wie weit um gespielt
von mir weg ist wenn ich erzählt ein
baum bin oder so siehst du mich obwohl
wenn ich mich nicht siehst du mich
trotzdem mal die armen leute ist
trotzdem gut aber jetzt wissen wir auf
jeden fall dass das ganze auf jeden fall
schon mal ganz gut funktioniert wir
haben auch wieder bei twitter gepostet
#fb blp können und so wieder so ein paar
tipps tricks sowas schreiben und
er meint nicht viele leute dass ich mich
mal um dinge kümmern soll dass wir hier
irgendwie so weil guck mal hier sind ja
diese kabeln diese koffer cable die wir
hier vorhaben
du warst du sowas ist spektakulär
gemacht endlich geht's weiter
er hat lange gewartet endlich soweit und
dafür kriegt abschläge in seine neueste
wir haben genauso lang und sie sich doch
wartet wie ihr aber wir wussten ja
einiges tun damit das alles läuft und
endlich es war ein weiter weg dieser war
steinig und schwer und naja wir freuen
uns so richtig drauf unsere richtigen
gliedmaßen zappeln zu lassen vorfreude
genau was ich muss erst mal kurz in den
us kinos gehen so jetzt bin ich im recht
genau was ich machen wollte ist diese
band hellsongs weil ich die für solche
dings brauche ich wollte solche wende
vor klatschen dass man diese kabel hier
nicht so sieht hatte ich mir dann
allerdings relativ schnell wieder
abgesprungen weil ich dann irgendwie
doch keinen bock drauf hatte
deswegen würde ich sagen dass ich mich
um ein jetpack einfach mal kümmere wir
können uns ja jetzt wieder weiter tipps
und tricks in die kommentare schreiben
wo ihr denkt ja das könnten die
gebrauchen
bei twitter kommt er jetzt gerade nicht
so viel an simon hörst du mich noch ich
höre ich noch aber du hast ein bisschen
echo heute es ist komisch hast du hast
du dein zimmer auf einmal anders
eingeräumt oder so person also also du
behalten sonst hast du so was nie ich
halle hatte ich kenne man theoretisch
schauen was du mich denn ganz normal
also bin ich es ist so jetzt besser
ich weiß nicht vielleicht vielleicht
also keine ahnung also vielleicht kommst
du einfach nur so vor ist so besser ich
jetzt jeder so ein bisschen umdrehe
probiert sie gerade mal ein paar sachen
nicht so jetzt mal den pegeln bisschen
runter
so leichten halb so als würde so ein
bisschen besser passt es so ja es ist
etwas besser etwas besser ich musste die
ganze noch ein bisschen neu einstellen
weil wegen neue pc und sondern kann auch
wir jetzt aber nicht ist aber nicht
dramatisch also lass dich nicht schlecht
ernte lässt sich trotzdem sehr schön wie
eh und je hassel es ist ein video
gesehen wo ich dann ein video gemacht
hat dass so ein club ist dazu etwas was
du hast ein video von zwei games
bist du glaubt ja ich weiß haben alle
darunter geschrieben die man meint ihr
liebevoll blabla du musst sprinten
springen und warum kriegt er und rennt
nur bei dem moment auch gedacht aber ich
bin nicht gesprungen ganz einfach ich
weiß dass man schneller ist aber ich bin
nicht gesprungen weil die tatsache war
sondern so eine brücke gesprungen bei
der welt quasi gegen die treppen
gesprungen und dann welche
hängengeblieben versteht also deswegen
bin ich nicht gesprungen und dann ich
weiß aber nicht wo hast du denn gesagt
ich hab es in dem video sagt der
australier gemacht und da hab ich habe
vor wiederantritt übrigens fällt gerade
ein
mir fällt gerade ein ich habe eben
comics video angeguckt und ja leute
schreibt im conny mal als tipp er ist
deswegen gestorben weil er ist halt so
dies das weißt du erst angelaufen
na gut wir haben erst mal vier minuten
nur um gequatscht sehr schön auch warte
mal jetzt bin ich außerdem falsche
profile twitter macht euch mal ein
projekt table verbesserte workbench ich
hab mich anziehen für diese folge
ich möchte mir eine porno kann kräften
und long vor links
ich glaube ich jetzt ein projekt table
machen dafür brauche ich da heißt das
dass das okay
ich brauche definitiv stone habe
nirgendwo stone
also portugal sonst nie wir haben keinen
richtigen stone ich weiß gar nicht ich
kenne die sachen alle nur aus alter mit
default sehen die ganzen edelsteine und
soja viel geiler aus
ich musste ganz schick ja ich bin zweck
eigentlich auch schicke ich werde glaube
ich das nicht tun aber ich werde
vielleicht erst mal kennen games ist mit
einer nachgerade ja ich recht kommen
nein wir können dich rest der monster
sind gott oh gott oh gott oh gott oh
gott oh gott oh gott oh gott wenn wir es
aber wie der sound ausgeschlagen
außerdem schlagen oder habe ich so
leitet options sounds ich kann immer
noch nicht schlafen ich hab' ich hab den
sound sowie aus du bist bei mir auch
derbe leise einfach in skype ich weiß
nicht
ja ich hab den minecraft sound gerade
auf 7% einfach nur ich hatte microsofts
50 prozent ebenfalls zu sein ich habe
davon ab ob das portal gemacht und das
war so laut habe ich ein bisschen leiser
gedreht jetzt ist der song komplett weg
bürgerhauses kaputt ja ich weiß das ist
ein krieg explodiert glaube ich nicht
sagen jetzt mal runde
ja wir können jetzt schneller machen
danach so was auch sehr viele leute
meinten war er dass wir in die in die
links welt gehen sollen in den twilight
forest ja da müssen wir so ein loch
graben und an diamanten ryan dunn und
dann wenn dann blumen drum herum machen
ja so was ich glaube das werde ich mal
machen jetzt aber nur wenn zwei jahren
habe ich bei einigen fehlte dann bitte
ja okay wir haben noch zwei ja wenn man
sogar drei ja ja ja ja ja manchmal wo er
dann noch ein egal
so wie wasser brauche ich dann dafür
noch warte hier habe ich ein eimer
so dann mache ich das so ich brauche in
zwei dings loch und blumen dafür brauche
ich noch mehr
also ich brauche was ein miniatur
blackpool ok morgenstern
ok dann kriege ich nicht so schnell nein
quatsch reporter jan bosse kein netter
stellen doch ein
doch nein nein ich brauche ein netter
stern
nein wurzeln nicht streitig machen das
portal hier erst mal guckt doch einfach
dann siehst du an dem was nicht nehmt
also ich brauchte das nicht bei der
portugal
du hast die porsche dann in der kiste
gefallen ach ja stimmt
deswegen brauche ich das nicht so warte
hier einmal ganz kurz unser portal hin
so ich weiß nicht klappt das jetzt mit
dem portal
wir können uns natürlich weiterhin immer
tipps und tricks in die kommentare
schreiben
ich mache es weil die lange volk gottes
hat geklappt was seid ihr müsst jetzt
vom ein fachgeschäft kommen hat das
forum switches angucken
welche etwas was hast du da gemacht nein
das ist einfach so rein beiden schwingel
einmal einig so du hast falsche hat sich
wieder zurück auf fox' aber nein ist
immer beide dritte homo du bist so blöd
nein ich komme nicht rein
dollar ich bin nicht drin
ach so ja da bleibt doch da erst mal bei
mir steht einfach nur gerade downloaden
okay an bertelsmann schwimmer erleben
ich hoffe da passiert ist nicht allzu
viel
simon kommentierte weil illegale
downloaden der server ist bei mir jetzt
abgestürzt alle exception java net
socket teilauto exception rietheim aus
als ob der unfreiheit sind wir ein
ganzes team nicht alle ausblenden aber
ich bin drin ich bin drin ich bin drin
heißt habe ich einen wenn du ihn ich bin
richtig findet ihr traders welt mein
gott oh mein gott ist das geil da hinten
sind rehe ohne gott oh mein gott ich
habe die worte kann dabei
ich kann nur allen portalen machen doch
ich habe ein paar tage macht aber man
kann sich zwischen den welten sicht
überhaupt egal komm rein warte ich muss
gucken ob ich wieder zurückkomme dann
kannst du mal rein
oh mein gott so eine fette fläche und
alles und blau und block und hier schon
hier um mein gott ich habe jetzt bin ich
in der nähe vom lager also die die idee
sind hier wie die kühe oh mein gott ist
dieser trend fort ist geil echt warte ja
ich gehe kurz raus und gucken ob alles
klappt dann kannst du auch mit rein
kommen die übrigen leute falls er denke
ich sehe aus wie der letzte schlag ich
habe gerade geschlafen weil ich bin ein
ziemlich gemacht hatte war gibt es auch
so andere ärzte die das sind alles sogar
die gleichen ärzte wie auch hatten um
mein gott warum bin ich nicht schon viel
eher rein gegangen und ich dir einfach
das ging ja du musst das und diamanten
reinwerfen ja was heißt denn nur ein
diamant ja gut ich komme jetzt wieder
raus so dort nur ding jetzt geht's
wieder download im tor
okay das geht relativ schnell sogar gold
ist drin ich bin mir da reingefallen
aber du kannst ruhig wieder du kannst
jetzt auch mit
und wenn du das portal das portal
wechselt dann liegt auch ein bisschen
beispiel
am 8
wir müssen mal die ganzen welcher hier
stopfen die wir verursacht haben
ich habe einen firefly der mann habe ich
nicht war das nicht bei diesem einen
bachelor oder was da gar nicht dabei in
diesem trailer for those links was wir
da bei diesem wetter passte die in
waldweiler dem eurospeedway scheiterte
hier firefly oder leuchtet mensch.de
cool das ja interessant das geht schnell
ich mache mal kommen wir ganz schnell
ich eine neue tür
neben schluck wasser
naja das portal was ist so schnell oder
wie ja wenn du einmal rein fenster durch
dann kriegst du so die dem speed
verloren
ich lasse heißt aus gleich ausprobieren
warte vier neue tweets mit hashtags fdp
warum sind bananen krumm sollen wir
diskutieren wie man die sonne
nachwachsen ganz langweilig ich will es
mal so maschinen warum dass wir
automatisch zu sachen abbauen
das will ich mal automatisch ja du
wolltest doch erst mal an deinen
charakter bauen ja aber für zwei
diamanten mehr also sagen wir alles von
erwarte ich schon mal ganz kurz noch
jetpack jetpack rucksack rucksack bacpac
bounce elektronik alter electric jackpot
jetpack das kann sogar machen müssen wir
nur wir brauchen dem bett box dafür gott
kacke ist kompliziert da brauchen wir re
batterien und ganzen scheiß das alles so
kompliziert dieses spiel
wir müssen erstmal ne definitiv sollten
das als nächstes spiel aber es einfach
aussuchen was wir auch können
[ __ ] ich bin durch das portal gefassten
täter rein um zu gucken
denn wir brauchen definitiv erst mal
einen elfer portal haben wir schon ein
netter portal simon simon was waren wir
schon mal im netz ja noch keiner
ich bin drin ich bin trader voll ist
geht es ja auch diamanten volks-ja gibt
es selten selten
ich gehe auf die suche jemanden ich
möchte ich möchte dinge
herold dingsbums bild wird aber ich find
dich was du weisst dass wir zusammen
besiegen nein mann der zum teil heftig
das war ich hier eigentlich doch die
skeptiker besiegen
ich hoffe ich helfe ich hoffe ich komme
du kommst alec dann ins spiel wenn drin
ich habe ein loch in europa ist durch
die wand gefahren eine assistentin
schaden genommen
ja ich nehme aber auch schaden
er hat etwas auf es mein essen ich hatte
keine essen mehr ja dann kommen ja ich
gebe essen doch ich habe essen
aber ich bin gleich tot aber ich bin ich
tot ich bin nicht die pächter die
kindernothilfe dreimal täglich auf ich
hoffe dieses spiel leider ist einfach
immer geschafft indem ich schaffe den
ofen dann dann guck mal was für
marseille
da haben wir boss besiegt aber ich bin
ja nicht wo ich bin im moment oder sms
sms und dann dein leben mal finden bin
dabei wenn dabei wie macht ihr nicht so
viel schaden gemacht die wir kaum
schaden warte ich noch mal portale ich
mache dir mein portal deine mittel falls
wir wieder raus willst so ich hab mir
damals portal gemacht okay das ist das
ist dann dann kommt sie beim portal
wieder raus ja man kann ihn nur am man
kann ihn nur am kopf treffen
ja ich sehe schon ich bin generiere mich
gerade noch ärztlich das portal gereist
ehrlich ist total gereist die falschen
aber egal ist was du siehst du das
siehst erleben sie das erleben ja der
hat auch noch ganz viele ganz wenige
dingsda hinten
ich komm ich bin jetzt da es im moment
moment
oh mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
gemacht doch alles kaputt was sie
einfach ist so gut getroffen
escada hunter wärme sieht was habe jetzt
gekriegt wir haben elf nager scale hab
ich was machen kann
ich würde sagen wir haben es ungefähr 15
minuten aufgenommen
ich würde sagen dass sein reiches kam
und das ist jetzt wenigstens ein finaler
bossfights zuzusagen weil in der voll
wahrnehmen jetzt 15 minuten als folge
hoher auf 15 wie der fernseher wegen was
er erlebt die reihenfolge wieder weil es
haben leute so lange warten ist boss
besiegt
ich wollte jahre wenn euch das gefallen
hat ja als kleine reinigung es so lang
nichts kam dann bewährt doch unsere
videos mit einem schönen deutlich nach
oben und schreibt einfach mal die
kommentare nager nager und ich würde
sagen der nächste schritt war einfach
mal auch noch mal so ein paar sachen
rein die wir hier bauen könnten
eventuell von den bedenken
und ja dann will ich sagen kümmern uns
dann in der nächsten folge darum und
werden euch dann ein wenig
beziehungsweise dann haben die
kommentare noch nicht gelesen aber wir
werden jetzt ein bisschen weiter bauen
aber wenn man mal wieder richtig bock
auf wechselt schreibt wirklich nagern
lager und dann ab jetzt jeden tag global
weiter auf 1900 lediglich für machen wie
einst um 19 uhr hat mal 19 uhr gute zeit
und dann sehen uns durch das pixi schöne
runde die jetzt abermals haus hier also
du bist allerdings würde ich sagen
bis zum nächsten mal schauen so ganz
kurz am break
ich muss eben